L'idée est de se dire d'abord
il doit exister ce salaire minimum,
c'est ce qu'impose la directive.
L'Europe sociale, elle existe vraiment.
On peut le dire.
Au travers de textes législatifs
comme le salaire minimum,
la transparence des salaires,
mais ça peut être aussi
le rôle des comités d'entreprise européens.
De gros sujets sur lesquels
on est particulièrement impliqués,
nous, Parti Démocrate européen
et évidemment MoDem.
Tout sujet de la protection sociale,
face à cette grande transition,
je pense à un dispositif
comme le Fonds Social Climat
qui va permettre d'accompagner
au niveau social ces grandes transitions
portées par Marie-Pierre Vedrenne.
On peut illustrer cette Europe sociale
par l'instauration d'un salaire minimum.
L'idée est de se dire d'abord
il doit exister ce salaire minimum.
C'est ce qu'impose la directive qui a été adoptée lors de
la présidence française de l'Union européenne,
y compris dans des pays où il n'y en a pas.
Faire monter les droits sociaux des travailleurs,
leur assurer un travail décent et digne.
C'est l'idée qu'il y a derrière ce texte.
Dans la construction de l'Europe sociale,
on peut vraiment dire que nous sommes
particulièrement impliqués au MoDem et au PDE.
C'est dans notre ADN,
c'est dans notre culture.
On défend une Europe aussi humaniste,
sociale et qui protège.
Merci l’Europe pour toutes ces avancées sociales.